welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of The Last
of Us episode nine the finale look for
the light an episode title that book
ends the title of episode one when
you're lost in the darkness completing
the Firefly catchphrase when you're
watching the darkness left for the light
which is ironic considering Joel does
the worst possible thing to the Firefly
cause let's break down this finale shot
by shot for the details you missed
references to the game some interesting
changes they made from the game and
whether Joel made the right choice here
also subscribe to our new channel the
Deep dive with even more pointed
analyzes into titles you love I did a
live stream of The Last of Us finale
last night where I answered a lot of
your questions support our growing
Network also by grabbing some merch at
nerdroid.shop like this last of us
inspired look for the light shirt hey
that's a total episode okay the episode
opens with a very pregnant Anna this is
Ellie's mother and she's played by
Ashley Johnson who played Ellie for the
games Johnson's known for a number of
roles including the waitress Captain
America flirted with in a deleted
subplot in the 2012 Avengers film and
her first role is Chrissy Seaver on
Growing Pains and her most credit
vehicle of roles on critical role on
YouTube she's awesome now in the game we
never actually meet Anna she's only
referred to when Marlene said she
promised Ellie's mother she'd take care
of her also there's no father depicted
here it leaves the full circumstances of
Ellie's conception a bit of a mystery as
it is in the games and also I think we'd
all struggle seeing a father figure
who's not Joel but this image of a lone
vulnerable woman running through nature
is kind of a horror archetype something
that we see an evil dead and we actually
saw a version of it here in this series
with the infected kid wandering through
the woods outside Boston in episode one
you could argue the same Woods that Anna
is now running through this endows
Ellie's origin with a bit of divine
mystery like the single mother of Moses
setting her baby down the Nile to one
day be a savior the name Ellie draws its
root from the Hebrew l meaning God Anna
calls out to other fireflies she hopes
will be in the house showing that she
fled here hoping that she would find
Firefly backup she was lost in the
darkness and looked for the light and
she found no light this episode is
really priming us to not feel very
optimistic for Firefly Redemption Ellie
hides in a room that was clearly a a
kid's bedroom the curtains have cartoon
vehicles and traffic signs but while
this may have been a nursery this will
also be her tomb she pulls out the
switchblade the one later carried by
Ellie but the pain is so severe she
drops it right as the runner is pounding
on this door and it is truly frightening
to see this Runner crawling on all fours
at top speed like a wolf it actually
recalls a charge made by mama in Mama
Anna manages to stab this runner in the
neck but even after the final stab you
can see cordyceps mouth tendrils
reaching out in one final you grasp
and since Johnson did voice and do all
the motion for Ellie in the game when
she cries here we are hearing the voice
of Ellie just makes for an interesting
mix with the baby Ellie in this scene
crying Anna notices the baby on the
floor and then notices the bite on her
leg so even she's not really sure
whether the baby was born before the
bite and she rushes to cut the umbilical
cord and as soon as she cuts it now the
baby stops crying now the exact timing
of this is left off camera which is
important and you know it let's all
acknowledge that we are in uncharted
waters when it comes to fictional
infections in prenatal Health we don't
know for sure if the cordyceps from a
leg bite could affect an actively
crowning fetus in some unique way to
make the baby immune or if Ellie's
immunity was a result of an antibody
rapidly forming at the moment of birth
but normally a newborn's immune system
systems aren't yet fully developed so
you could say it's possible that Ellie
since conception had a genetic condition
and this was really just her first test
then again later Marley says that the
doctor thinks Ellie has had cordyceps
since birth and that the quarter step
she has produces a chemical Messenger to
make cordyceps think she's cordyceps too
but there remain some confusing aspects
about this that we'll talk about later
Anna tells her newborn daughter I got
you exactly what Joel tells his baby
girl at the end of episode 8. now it is
interesting how this flashback is
bisected by the episode's opening
credits as opposed to having the whole
flashback contained within the cold open
and then have the credits this
structural Choice results in the fungal
outgrowth of the opening critic imagery
Being Framed as an inner process
happening within Ellie and Anna's bodies
so when this fungus forms a human face
as it does every episode we now see it
as the face of Anna and when there are
two figures left whereas every episode
before we've seen them as Joel and Ellie
now we can look at them as a mother and
a daughter for every step Ellie has
taken her mother has been there with her
and both of them have this tragic fungal
link so when Marlene finds Anna Anna has
the knife to her throat she's ready to
kill herself the moment she begins to
feel herself turning she says she didn't
want to nurse the baby and that's
because nursing mom's milk has
antibodies that helps newborn's immune
systems form she didn't want any kind of
fluid exchange and I insisted she cut
the cord before she was bitten but in
truth she does not know she is lying to
Marlene just as Joel will lie to Ellie
about the fireflies at the end of the
episode therefore this episode opens and
closes with a lie and not even Noble
lies told in the interests of all
Society but lies really told out of
self-serving love this lie will haunt
Ellie like a curse as her caretakers lie
to keep her from getting killed baby
Ellie cries at the sound of The Gunshot
that kills Anna and even though there's
no way Ellie could remember this today
we cut from these newborn cries to Ellie
meditating now as if deep down she knows
the cost of these lies the cost of Lies
is actually the theme of Craig Mason's
past amazing HBO series Chernobyl what
is the cost of Lies is really the
opening line of the pilot actually and
you can see that the now influencing
Mason's work on the Last of Us as he and
Neil druckman have explored another
version of that what they have called
the danger of unconditional love when
you love someone so absolutely that you
defy the greater societal good because
love while often seen as a wonderful
redeeming thing in fiction can also be a
blinding toxic force on their way into
Salt Lake City Joel calls to Ellie a few
times but she zones out on your way into
Salt Lake City in the game at least
similarly a bit Spacey she doesn't
always reply to Joel when he talks to
her and I love how they adapted that
here Joel has found a can of ravioli
Chef Boyardee which is what they wolf
down while camping in episode four Joe
also scavenges a Boggle from this RV
Which is less depressing than the photo
in the game you find with forgive us
written on the back we're really seeing
Joel starting to psychologically Nest he
tells Ellie he saw a guitar in the RV
and as in the game he tells her he wants
to teach her how to play we saw a guitar
in the background of his home back in
episode one and Ellie playing the guitar
plays a big role in part two of the
games the building they passed through
has red tarps hanging over the
scaffolding making a foreboding Vibe
when Joel is chasing Ellie that gets
resolved nicely with the giraffes it
actually goes down the same way in the
games Ellie leaves Joel hanging with the
ladder and he keeps trying to catch up
to her so they both can get to an
opening and see the passing drafts this
season is actually teased giraffes in a
few places there's a stuffed giraffe on
the ground as Joel Tess and Ellie left
Boston in episode two there's a draft
poster on the wall of that teenage
girl's bedroom back in Jackson and fun
fact about giraffes they don't have
larynxes no voice boxes so when they
scream nothing comes out and the music
in this section is such a sweet relief
it's the same string music that played
over Bill and Frank's last day in
Lincoln in episode three
[Music]
but unlike the game they actually feed
the giraffe here making this moment feel
like that's sweet calm between the
storms beat in Jurassic Park when a
reluctant Father Figure Dr Grant and
those kids beat a Brachiosaurus Joel and
Ellie gaze out over the baseball field
and Ellie says you can't deny that view
calling back a similar moment when they
were looking out over the city of Boston
in episode 2. Joel offers Ellie a chance
to turn back but Ellie says they have to
go through with it that it can't all be
for nothing which sets up Joel's
ultimate choice to be that much more
heartbreaking because he is robbing her
of the possibility of their Journey
having a real impact on the world or
making Sam's death matter The Last of Us
is wrap it up and that means it's time
to reveal the winner of the quit
apocalypse Ellie vs Joel contest but
first who's
well quick makes a variety of products
to keep your mouth free of cordyceps and
other pre-apocalypse bits of Gunk and
crud quips electric toothbrush has timed
Sonic vibrations with 30 second pulses
to guide a dentist's recommended two
minute clean
quip is a water flosser that can give
you a gentle or deep clean at the touch
of a button and quips gum starter kit
fits in just about any purse or pocket
for on-the-go Dental Health now for the
past weeks you've all been voting and
the winner of the quipocalypses
if you voted for Joel be on the lookout
for an email from quip with your prize
and if you voted for Ellie sorry but I
guess you've been left behind hey if you
missed the contest no worries you can
still be part of the quipocalypse just
tag new rockstars and quip on Instagram
and show us what one item you would need
for the apocalypse you could be featured
on our social media pages so make sure
you are following and subscribed but if
you've had enough of the apocalypse and
just want to up your oral hygiene game
go to getquip.com new rockstars and
you'll get 20 off and equip water
flosser equipped toothbrush or equipped
gum starter kit that's
g-e-t-q-u-i-p.com Slash new rockstars
for 20 off any floss or toothbrush or
gum starter kit they find an army triage
camp where Joel went to get treated for
the bullet wound that they mentioned
back in episode three some mystery man
who shot and missed whom Joel now
reveals as himself in the game Joel
considered suicide after Sarah died but
here he actually attempted it similarly
we should note as Ellie's biological
mother Anna with the Knight nearly
killing herself the danger of
unconditional love all this time jolist
had that scar on his Temple and Ellie
has had the burn scar over her eyebrow
from some past incidents she and Riley
referred to that happened at the
7-Eleven Joel says that when he went to
pull the trigger he flinched and still
doesn't know why it might be because
deep down he knew that there was someone
out there he would love just as much
they read more puns from will
Livingston's no pun intended people are
making apocalypse jokes like there's no
tomorrow I love how it's not too soon
it's just topical but the third joke is
what did the green grapes say to the
purple grape breathe you idiot and it's
here that they get hit with the stun
grenade from the fireflies which is a
major change from the game there Joel
and Ellie have a much more extended
sequence where they go under the tunnels
they run into multiple bloaters and they
get caught in a dangerous Rush of water
that Ellie almost drowns in because
remember she cannot swim so that Joel
has to perform chest compressions when
the fireflies knock them out so breathe
you idiot maybe a nod to what Joel was
thinking during that CPR in the game and
though it wakes up to Marlene the Queen
of Hearts herself in our Wonderland she
explains that Ellie's cordyceps grows in
her brain that Elias had it since birth
they think and that it sends a chemical
Messenger to tell other quarter steps
that she is quarter steps too now the
issue with this is even though that bite
that Ellie got in the mall never grew
past her arm that she can receive bites
and not get further infected other
infected clickers and Runners and
bloaters have still looked at Ellie as a
Target to buy fight she still smells
like fresh meat to external cordyceps
she doesn't have that kind of hive mind
effect that the infected had with Tess
so that chemical messenger may be real
but it only exists within Ellie's body
it doesn't extend to other infected who
will still rip her apart so this
chemical messenger would be kind of a
cure but really just a half measure all
it would do is make it so that a bite
wouldn't turn you which is valuable but
you would still have all these Runners
and clickers and bloaters trying to rip
your head off I just think this gives a
bit more of a reason for Joel to call
on this procedure would it make
that much of a difference to just
inoculate a bunch of people if they're
still millions of clickers running
around the world is probably a bit too
far gone to Really Turn The Tide but
either way this ethical dilemma not
trusting science to make the executive
decision has really been seated from the
beginning that 1960s talk show where the
leading epidemiology failed to prevent
this Vedra killing a kid for Joel To
Burn Ellie not trusting her fedra
education where her teachers would
refuse to admit the history of how they
let the world go to Bill thinking
the government we're all Nazis Kathleen
executing Kansas City's doctor in Cold
Blood they all now live in a world where
science and medicine have failed
Humanity epically so short-term needs
have taken a higher priority Joel is
marched out but he stops to take note of
the floor map and spots that Pediatrics
and pediatric surgery are on level six
so Joel kills the guards and
methodically goes to town on the
fireflies now in the game this is really
the final Challenge and it's hard as
hell you have to do a mixture of
sneaking around and misdirection in
perfectly timed headshots to get past
all the fireflies you gotta pick your
battles some are worth just sneaking
past and not killing and as you are
playing this you just feel like a
horrible person you're an active shooter
with an objective to stop the world's
possible salvation so this sequence is
shot not as a thrilling action sequence
but really just a cold-hearted line of
executions where the gunfire and action
sounds are pushed in the background in a
dark version of the main Show's theme
plays over it all and we see each cell
hit the ground we are taking account of
every person Joel kills including one
guy who surrenders and Joel kills anyway
at one point we see Joel switching to an
assault rifle this is something that
happens about halfway through this stage
of the game and it definitely gives you
a leg up and Joel makes it all the way
to Pediatrics and he passes a mural of
an elephant and a monkey and on the
other side of the wall it's harder to
see in Joel's periphery but a giraffe
that silent gentle giant that
represented Joel's peaceful nesting with
Ellie at this moment means nothing to
him there is no peace in his heart as in
the game Joel finds Ellie on that
operating table with a doctor and two
nurses and Joel executes the doctor and
takes Ellie and the camera stays on this
dead surgeon for a moment this ain't an
accident it said some things to come
more on this in spoiler corner but
Carrie and Ellie to the elevator in the
game is also pretty big challenges you
have to Sprint past the gunfire while
not being able to shoot back because
Ellie's in your arms Joel runs into
Marlene in the parking garage who in
this version I thought was interesting
left out the threat that Ellie could get
raped by Raiders in the future but what
we saw with David last episode was
pretty extreme but smartly they leave in
when one of my favorite structural
choices from the game we cut from Joel
considering Marlene's points directly to
Joel driving looking like he's alone in
the car because Ellie's not in the front
seat with him and there is this look of
grief on his face and for a moment we
think he is alone and he left Ellie back
at the hospital but a moment later we
see Ellie shifting in the back seat and
we realize he's stuck to his guns and
what petropascal does here is so good he
closes his eyes and he shakes his head
slightly making us think that he just
made a terrible terrible mistake and for
a second we really do think did he just
leave Ellie behind but no now we realize
his anguish that he's feeling is
actually guilt for making the selfish
decision to save Ellie at the expense of
the whole world like Anna lying to
Marlene about the timing of Ellie's
birth in the opening now Joel lies to
Ellie he says the fireflies doctors had
failed to derive a cure from dozens of
immune people the doctors they couldn't
make any of it work we've actually
they've stopped looking for a cure yeah
I love how the bang of Joel's shooting
Marlene interrupts the flow of Joel's
sentence now we see how Joel did not
give Marlene even a chance
you just come after her
yeah Joel knows that to leave anyone
anyone left behind from Salt Lake City
is going to be creating an enemy who
will come back for Ellie and himself
they return to Wyoming and as they take
their final hike toward Jackson Joel
finally begins to talk about Sarah
something he never allowed himself to do
in front of Ellie and it's because he
can imagine Ellie and Sarah being
friends and making each other laugh and
as in the game in this final moment
Ellie Paces in frustration reveals what
really happened when she was bitten how
she was with her best friend Riley and
she is carried that guilt with her along
with the deaths of Tess and Sam Joel
says that's not on her but Ellie Cuts
him off saying swear to me that
everything you said about the fireflies
is true
swear and we end on just a long pause as
Bella Ramsay emotes an extreme close-up
that she is really thinking this over
going back and forth before she finally
decides
okay
and we cut to Black end of season this
okay was a choice by Ellie I think she
knows that Joel was probably lying to
her or at least not telling the complete
truth and she knows that there will be
consequences for that lie someday but
she's mature enough now to know that to
step forward and accept a version of
reality is just a choice every adult has
to make at some point previously her
daughterly affection for Joel was
something she could just offer with
youthful Glee and humor but now she's
more of a sequel and she feels the
weight that this kind of selfish
companionship Bears on the rest of the
world she knows the cost of lies and she
feels the danger of Love okay on to
spoiler Corner if you played part two of
the games you know that doctor is Dr
Jerry Anderson father of everyone's
favorite character Abby Abby who won
final spoiler warning seriously if you
don't know what happens in part two of
the game and you don't want to know stop
watching okay Abby Abby Abby Abby Abby
Abby Abby infamously catches up to Joel
after Joel saved her ass and she kills
him in front of Ellie to avenge Joel for
killing her doctor father actually when
Marlene asks Joel what Ellie would
decide it's a valid question because
it's Ellie's decision whether or not she
wants to give up her life or something
but Marlene asking this was also
grounded in a conversation that she has
with Dr Jerry in a flashback in part two
of the game when Marlene asks if he
would be willing to sacrifice his
daughter's life and Abby later tells her
dad that she'd be willing to do it I
predict HBO is going to push Mason and
druckman and do the Last of Us for at
least three seasons and at the end of
season 2 will be Joel's death and
whoever the cast is Abby keep that
actress off social media because we'll
need to protect her at all cats people
are not gonna like her I have loved
breaking down the last of us this season
please subscribe to our new channel the
Deep dive and support this growing
Network by grabbing something from
nerdrion.shop you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at EA boss follow
new rockstars And subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thanks